we all know what pi the number looks
like but this is what it sounds like so
what I've done is I've taken the numbers
the digits of pi 3.14159 and I've mapped
those onto a c-major scale so basically
I've said one is C 2 is d 3 is e 4 is F
5 is G etc and I've gone all the way up
1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 0 and those what you
can hear in the background is the result
of a computer program which takes those
digits converts them to the frequencies
of those notes converts them to the
sound of those notes and then plays it
back so that's what you're hearing in
the background which when I first did it
I guess I thought it was going to sound
not particularly musical but it's
remarkable just in some places how
musical it can sound
pi is a transcendental number it's this
jumble of digits you'd expect it would
sound very very random or almost like
white noise and prata well if we speed
that up quite a bit it will sound quite
atonal let's put it that way but because
I've mapped it on to this you know a
simple very simple musical scale C major
it you get this you know on occasion you
get these quite little nice little
musical motifs I would argue they don't
repeat we can't play it on other
instruments and then you start to get a
bit more character and a bit more feel
as well I have really geeked out here
I've taken the first 42 digits of pi and
then what I've done is done this is so I
learned to play guitar I didn't over I
know lessons so those guitarists who
aren't particularly good at reading
standard music notation do something
called guitar tablature which is sort of
the idiots version of writing down music
three one four one five nine two six
five three five eight nine seven nine
I'll start now
and then we've got
can you do that again and this time talk
me through it as you don't you ask a lot
Brady oh I'll try
so three one four one five nine Bend up
to nine back to two and then we've got
six five three five eight nine and then
back down to seven and up tonight you
want it again
which of family was a really really
important 20th century physicist made
contributions right across the board
part had this really very interesting
point about by PI that he brought up
quite amusing point ins in some regards
and he noted that at the 760 second
digit of pi you get this six nines in a
row and you know if you look at that
given that pi is meant to be this
irrational number that seems very very
very unusual and particularly because it
occurs so early on in the sequence the
next time that set of number of
recurring set of numbers occurs it's
something like 4 remember the 190,000
digit and again it turns out to be nines
which is from some aspects rather rather
surprising and so finally made the joke
that what he'd really like to do is to
learn PI off and there's obviously that
very many people who like to learn PI
off to X number of digits I can I know
it barely past the sixth digit but
people can learn it after many hundreds
of digits Feynman wanted to learn it off
to the seven hundred and sixty second
digit and then go pi is 3.14 and a nine
nine nine nine nine and so on sort of
pretending that it's rational beyond
that point and irritating all those
people who have learned off all the rest
of the digits because it's a rational
beyond our point so what we're going to
do now is listen to the Fineman point
where for that was it
that was the note so because they all
bleed into each other the only reason
you can differentiate them cuz the pitch
is changing so it bleeds into each other
you wanna hear it again
pi is random pi goes forever so
somewhere in pi is Beethoven's fifth
yeah but you've got to remember that
we're actually in the key of c-major
here so I've mapped that onto a
particular King so things outside that
key like Beethoven's fifth for example
or it's impossible for them to ring and
come in here because you need investing
in a key of C you don't have any flats
or sharps for Beethoven's fifth you have
to have those flats and sharps in there
so you don't know those were but there
are pieces of music like for example doe
a deer a female deer one two three one
three one three
I'm shall be able to find out somewhere
is it inevitable that my mobile phone
number your tax number is somewhere in
PI well if it repeats to in repeat if it
extends to infinity then yes there's a
finite probability of finding those
numbers somewhere in there indeed you
might argue that you know if you called
our DNA structure and couldn't code the
genome perhaps if it extends to infinity
we may well all be called it somewhere
in PI